انا اصدرها لدعاء العام الالمانيه اليوم
الاربعاء اوامره باعتقالي 25 فردا يجتبه
في انتائهم الى حركه مواطن الرايه وقالت
متحدثه باسم للدعاء العام في كاستلو ان
السلطات شنت الحمله في 11 ولايه المانيه
ولم يتم الاعلان بعد عن مزيد من التفاصيل
وافادت الاستخبارات العسكريه الالمانيه
لان من بين المجتبها فيهم جنديا نشطا في
القوات الخاصه للجيش وعددا من جنود
الاحتياط يسكنوا انا اعضاء حركه المواطنين
الرايخ لا يعترفون بالدوله الالمانيه
الحديثه التي تاسست بعد انهيار النازيه
ولا بقوانينها ويمتنعون عن دفع ضرائب
ومخصصات الاجتماعيه ويصرون على ان
الامبراطوريه الالمانيه لا تزال قائمه
الادعاء العام الالماني قال في بيان ان
المتهمين اسسوا ذراعا عسكريه تهدف الى
القضاء على دوله القانون الديمقراطيه على
مستوى البلديات والمقاطعات الادعاء العام
الى ان بعض اعضاء الذراع العسكريه
المشتبهي فيهم خدموا في الجيش الالماني
بحسب البيانات فان الهيئه المركزيه للحركه
يطلق عليها اسم المجلس وتم تشكيلها على
غرار مجلس الوزراء في الحكومه النظاميه اي
تتضمن وزارات مثل العدل والخارجيه والصحه
كما ذكر لدعاء العام ان اعضاء المجلس
يجتمعون بانتظام منذ نوفمبر 2021 من اجل
التخطيطي للاستناء على السلطه في المانيا
وانشائي هياكل دوله خاصه بها
قال وزير العدل الالماني عمليه كبرى اذا
لمكافحه الارهاب تجري منذ صباح اليوم
واشار الوزير الى ان المدعي العام
الفيدراليه الالماني يحقق في شبكه ارهابيه
مشتبه فيها من حركه مواطنيه ارايخ واضاف
ان العمليه جاءت على
عقاب في التخطيط لهجوم مسلح على مؤسسات
الدستوريه
الى برلين الان مع مراسله الجزيره عيسى
طيبه مرحبا بك من جديد عيسى اذن لنحدث هذه
الاخبار والمعلومات الجديده التي وردت عن
عن هذا المجلس حسب ما ذكر وهذا التغلغل
داخل البلديات والمقاطعات
ربما ابدا بالعاجل الذي ورد منذ قليل في
برلين اعتقلت
القياديه السياسيه في حزب البديل وعضوه
البوتسطاقه السابق سابقا مالك
في بيتها في منطقه فانزي ببرلين السادسه
صباحا هذا اليوم
الخبر وردته
[موسيقى]
الالمانيه
السياسيه الالمانيه والقياديه في حزب
البديل وعضوه البندق سابقا تم اعتقالها من
طرف السلطات الامنيه السادسه صباحا
بتوقيت المحلي بمنطقه برلين النقطه
الثانيه ايضا تم اعتقال همم مواطن الماني
يعرف بها الامير هنريش الثالث عشر وهمم
يبلغ من العمر 71 عاما نعتقل في فرانكفورت
وتقول بحسب ما اورده التلفزيون الالماني
همم كان همم تم تعيينهم من طرف التنظيم
تنظيم مواطنين رايح بان يكون رئيسا للمجلس
ويقصد بهما انا مجلس الوزراء الذي يضم
مجموعه من الوزراء ايضا تم اعتقال تنظيم
اخر في منطقه كوبلانس وهذه التنظيم كان
ينوي القيام
بمجموعه من الاعمال من بينها قطع الكهرباء
في عمومه المانيا والقيام بعمليه تمرد
ايضا همم في باب لبنشتاين تم ايقاف او
تعليق عامه العمده بسبب انه قام
بحفل استقبال السيد هنرش الثالث عشر همم
هذا المواطن الالماني الذي يبدو انه من
سليل للعائله الامبراطوريه والذي اراد
مواطن والرايه ان يكون عضوا ان يكون عضوا
وقائدا للحكومه التي عينها تنظيم الرايخ
هذه هي الاخبار الحديثه التي اعلنتها
السلطات الالمانيه الان وهي اخبار تدل بان
الاعتقالات تمس ايضا سياسيين سابقين في
المانيا او قياديين في في في حزب البديل
الذي ايضا اعلنت السلطات بانه اعلنت
الصحيفه بان هذا الاعتقال تم صباح هذا
اليوم هناك حديث ايضا بان السفاره الروسيه
في برلين ايضا ناقت بنفسها عن هذه
الاعتقالات واعلانات بان لا علاقه لها
بهذا التنظيم لا من قريب ولا من بعيد وهي
في الحقيقه الان اا اشاره لماذا لان هناك
حديث بان من بين المعتقلين شخصيات لها
الصلات بموسكو وبالتالي هذه المعلومات لم
تؤكدها السلطات وبعد لكن الحديث في وسائل
الاعلام
اريد ان هناك اطراف معين لديها علاقه على
الاقل مع الصفار الروسيه في برلين ننتظر
اخر ما يصدر من النائب العام او من وزاره
العدل التي هي منذ الصباح تجلب تصريحات
حول هذه العامليه التي وصفتها بانها عمليه
لمكافحه الارهاب نعم
شكرا عيسى اذا نو